We have some tremendous discussions happening
on the David Pakman show sub Reddit.
We have more than 21000 of our viewers and
listeners subscribed for free.
I'm selling you nothing here.
It's just a place to discuss politics.
David Pakman dot com slash Reddit is the place
to find it.
User lefty guitarist posted a relevant thread
about how a vaccine won't be enough to end
the pandemic.
And the user points out accurately that there
are many people anticipating the vaccine and
that it will help.
But that social distancing and mask wearing
and avoiding large crowds are probably going
to be necessary for some time.
And there's a few reasons why.
No.
One.
The vaccine does not give you 100 percent
immunity.
Number two, there's going to be a ton of people
that don't get the vaccine.
There have been people so propagandized in
this country to believe that, you know, Bill
Gates wants to microchip you with the vaccine
or whatever, that there's going to be a ton
of people that just opt out.
So this is absolutely correct.
And there's another point.
Much like with the polio vaccine, where there
was an initial vaccine that was not particularly
effective and over time they became more effective.
Once the vaccine is out, both for production
reasons and for effectiveness reasons, it's
still going to be a build to getting back
to a point where we can say we can go back
to normal.
So in total, by the time this is all said
and done, going back to January or so, which
is, you know, when we had our first case,
we're probably talking about a two year period.
Fully, fully.
Although hopefully a lot of sort of normal
day to day will return in the winter or early
spring of 2021.
User Wagon Wheel.
What says David, might not be aware, but Trump
can't get booed throwing out the first pitch
because there are no fans in attendance at
baseball games this baseball season.
That's absolutely correct.
And in that I made a mistake earlier this
week when we covered Donald Trump canceling
his first pitch event at the Yankee Stadium
at at the Yankee Red Sox game at Yankee Stadium
on August 15th.
And it turned out that it was never scheduled.
I said there are three reasons.
One, Trump doesn't really know how to throw
a baseball.
Number two, Trump doesn't want to get booed.
And number three, Trump doesn't want to be
there as players kneel during the anthem.
Number two was wrong because there were no
fans and that I was incorrect about that.
I apologize for having misled you to the extent
that I did.
It was accidental.
And this this viewer is completely right.
Join the discussion yourself at David Pakman
dot com slash.
Read it.
We have moderators.
We have standards that are applied to the
sub Reddit.
And I invite you to come in and participate